Das ist wirklich paradox: Obwohl die Meere
eigentlich immer wärmer werden, hat ein US-Forschungsteam
jetzt eine Region der Erde aufgespürt, die
immer kälter wird.
Konkret geht es um die Tiefen des Pazifischen
Ozeans.
Dort wird das Wasser unterhalb von 2.000 Metern
Tiefe immer kälter.
Was die “Kleine Eiszeit” damit zu tun
hat und warum dieses Ergebnis bedeutet, dass
es höchste Zeit ist, unsere aktuellen Klimamodelle
zu überarbeiten, erfahrt ihr jetzt bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich verblüffende Sciencevideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Los geht’s.
Herzlich willkommen!
Die Auswertung historischer Messungen enthüllte
das überraschende Phänomen: Ganz im Gegensatz
zu dem Temperaturtrend auf der Erdoberfläche
und in den oberen Regionen der Meere wird
es im tiefen Pazifik kälter.
Und zwar um 0,02 Grad pro Jahrhundert, so
ein US-Forschungsteam in einer aktuellen Studie.
Die Erklärung für dieses Ergebnis liefern
die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
gleich mit.
Schuld ist wohl die sogenannte “Kleine Eiszeit”,
auf die das Wasser der pazifischen Tiefsee
mit einer Verzögerung von mehreren Jahrhunderten
reagiert.
Aber von vorne: Die “Kleine Eiszeit”,
Sie herrschte zwischen 1250 und 1900 auf der
Nordhalbkugel.
Vorher war das Klima eher warm, sodass sogar
die Menschen in Norwegen Getreide anbauen
konnten.
Doch dann gab es einen Umschwung.
Extremwinter sorgten dafür, dass sogar die
Themse in London und die Kanäle in den Niederlanden
zugefroren waren.
Viele Menschen starben, denn es herrschten
Hungersnöte und Seuchen.
Bei der “Kleinen Eiszeit” handelte es
sich im Gegensatz zu der klimatischen Entwicklung
heutzutage allerdings um eine natürliche
Variation des Klimas und wurde nicht durch
die Menschen vorangetrieben.
Von dieser Kälte ist tatsächlich etwas geblieben
und zwar im Pazifischen Ozean.
Sein Tiefenwasser reagiert also erst jetzt,
Jahrhunderte später, auf die “Kleine Eiszeit”.
Zurückzuführen ist dies wohl auf die sehr
langsame Zirkulation der Wassermassen innerhalb
des pazifischen Ozeans.
Dazu die Forscherin Jake Gebbie, die an der
Untersuchung beteiligt war: “Diese Gewässer
sind so alt und seit so langer Zeit nicht
mehr an der Oberfläche gewesen, sie erinnern
sich quasi noch daran, was vor Hunderten von
Jahren geschah, als Europa einige der kältesten
Winter der Geschichte erlebte.”
Bei ihrer Analyse griff das Forschungsteam
auf Messungen aus den 1870er-Jahren zurück
und verglich dieses mit aktuelleren Messdaten
aus den 1990er-Jahren.
Doch um falsche Ergebnisse auszuschließen,
mussten die Fachleute einige Fehlmessungen
aus den 1870er-Jahren korrigieren.
Damals fand die weltweit erste moderne Expedition
statt, um den Meeresboden und die Ozeane systematisch
unter die Lupe zu nehmen.
Und zwar an Bord der “HMS Challenger”,
von der aus insgesamt 5.000 Temperaturmessungen
durchgeführt wurden.
Die damals angewandte Methode war nicht nur
ein riesiger Arbeitsaufwand, sondern gilt
heutzutage als längst überholt.
Einzelne Thermometer wurden damals an Seilen
ins Wasser abgelassen, um dann die Temperatur
abzulesen.
Dazu Peter Huybers von der Harvard-University:
“Wir haben diese historischen Daten auf
Abweichungen überprüft und eine Vielzahl
von Korrekturen durchgeführt.
Dabei ging es um Aspekte wie Druckeinflüsse
auf die Thermometer und Dehnungseffekte bei
den Hanfseilen, die zum Absenken der Thermometer
genutzt wurden”.
Am Ende zeigte der Vergleich der Temperaturmessungen
von heute und damals aber das, was das Forschungsteam
auch schon in seinem Modell vermutet hatte:
Große Teile des Pazifiks sind in einer Tiefe
von 2.000 Metern abgekühlt.
Die Wassermassen darüber dagegen erwärmen
sich.
Anders dagegen sieht es im Atlantik aus - dort
hat sich auch das Tiefenwasser seit den 1870er-Jahren
erwärmt und spiegelt somit die Klimaerwärmung
in den letzten Jahrhunderten.
Laut der aktuellen Studie findet zwar auch
hier eine Verzögerung zwischen Tiefsee und
Oberfläche statt.
Allerdings liegt sie im Atlantik wohl nur
bei einem bis vier Jahrhunderte.
Dazu die Erklärung der Wissenschaftler: “Die
pazifischen Tiefenwasser haben wegen ihrer
stärkeren Isolation von der Oberfläche ein
längeres Gedächtnis als der Atlantik“.
So könne es im Pazifik 800 bis 1.400 Jahre
dauern, ehe sich auch in Wassertiefen von
mehr als zwei Kilometern die Temperaturveränderungen
der Oberfläche niederschlagen.
Das Ergebnis macht deutlich, dass Klimazustände
sehr lange ihre Spuren in den Gewässern hinterlassen.
Mindestens genauso spannend ist aber der Einfluss
der Ozeane auf das heutige Klima.
Denn klar ist, dass diese als ein wichtiger
Klimapuffer im Klimawandel fungieren, denn
sie nehmen sowohl CO2 als auch Wärme aus
der Atmosphäre auf.
Doch die neuen Studienergebnisse machen deutlich,
dass die oberen Wassermassen des Pazifiks
nicht so viel Wärme aufgenommen haben, wie
wir bisher angenommen hatten.
Somit wäre seine Pufferwirkung kleiner als
gedacht, was bedenklich ist.
Dieses Ergebnis erfordert also auch, dass
aktuelle Klimamodelle angepasst werden!
Umfassend könnt ihr euch übrigens über
den Klimawandel bei Raumzeit Vlog der Zukunft
informieren.
Dafür hier klicken auf das Video Klimawandel
- Fakt oder Fiktion.
Unbedingt ansehen und natürlich abonnieren!
Ansonsten bis dann, bleibt dran!